Ooh...
Spooky.
*creepy music*
Oh! That's different.
Are we in a city?
Uh huhhh...
Okay...
Alright...
Interesting...
*door slams* Oh, hi.
*loud bang on door* Okay, that's weird. *bang*  Cool.
All righty, then. Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to the Hello Neighbor BETA.
Now, this is the BETA; it is no longer in ALPHA.
They say the game is good enough to be able to put it into beta so that's exactly what we're gonna be doing here.
So I've got the... yeahm.. I do-
I don't know about the shape of my head, but I don't think these binoculars are gonna fit it.
Well, amazingly they do and I can still see the binoculars. So.. it's out of ALPHA, which means that it's in a better playable state,
RIGHT??? Coool. (nope)
Great, gonna throw that away.
Hello. Ooh. Oh, I can see myself! I'm so...
handsome...
Alright. Yeah, smooooth out that telegram.
I don't know what the fuck I just saw, but it was not normal human motion.  Why- *laugh* What am I doing?? I didn't even read it!
Okay... well, I guess I got invited somewhere or I'm moving, so I guess I get to get- get the frick out of here.
Heyyy! Let me pack up my meager belongings.
My absolute nothingness. I have nothing. I own nothing. I am nothing. I'm just a big nothing!
Oh, there's my key. Why's my key in my drawer?
I'm gonna key something REAL GOOD. You want to get keyed? *keying sounds*
Okay, that didn't work. Alright, whatever. Oh, I'M in the city!
Flip-flap. Okay. Alright then. ''Find the key...Put the key in the suitcase.''
Uh! Eeh.
Got it. Nailed it. ''Find the house'' *laughter*
Find the house?
With the bi-nocs?
Nope, about to throw it out the window. I don't think that's it. I'm gonna take a lookee for you.
Where you at, house-y wouse-y? I can't move until I see it!
Oh boy, I hope I see it! I sure want to move out of this hellhole of a city!
Where are you? Okay, that's not it.That's obviously not it. Okay. Can I open my-
Ooh...
Uh, I'm so hesitant.
What am I looking pensively at? It's not like there's much to memory here.
No reminiscent in this place.
Just... future potential.
Always looking forward to the future.
Okay, well.
Ah. Aaaah!
NOW we're in the neighborhood! Oh, I'm driving. Hello, neighbor.
Ah, I see your place is less crazy than it was. More boarded up than it has been in the past.
Also, why am I pulling into HIS driveway?
Wait, is this MY house?
Thwomp.
Wait, this is MY house? Wait a minute!
Wait a hinky honky second here. Wait a hink horkan second. Wait a moo-mont (moment).
Hang on a second.
Ah, I'm seeing something here.
*Soft chuckles*
You just pull it off, you're so strong. I know you can do it.
*Grunts*
Nope, never mind. Too weak. Too wimpy. Very wimpy baby. all right, what do I got here?
(Accent) Do I got something in the boot of me car?
Oh, I do have it something in the boot of me car
All right! Diddly-doo~
Eh, eugh! Guh, goo!
Ah, Eeh!
Ooh! Urr!
Aaah...
Oooooh!
Wow!
Oh, good! Something staring at me from my closet, that's niiiiice.
Alright, Imma go over here, hang on a second.
I need to see what's in this house. If anything's still here. Scoosh! No? This weird Dr. Seuss-style neighborhood?
No, nothing? All right. Okay! Into my house I go, then. I trust this! Got a great deal on this bad boy.
Ah, yeah. Oh, good stuff. Ah-
*Strong sniff*
Mm, you can smell the rich history in this place here. Oh, hell-
*Drawers opening*
What was that?
Hello! No, can't open that one, that weird door don't open.
Hmm!
Mysteriously, all the doors in my new place are locked.
Oh!
Free furniture! Great! I'm gonna save so much money at Ikea! Alright let's get my stuff in.. whatever my stuff is.
Is this my only stuff? One box of stuff here? All I need?
Moving in. Welp, moved in! That felt good!
What else do I need? This one chair! Also I have chair. Anybody know that I have chair? It's my stuff.
Anybody need more stuff? Nah, I don't think so. Ooh! Another box! I'm rich. I've got a bounty of stUFF!
Wait, can I not move this one? This is permanently stuck to my car, I guess. I got a bucket!
I have one bucket. Anybody wanna know what my bucket is?
Okay, never mind then..
OK!
Oh...
Oh, no...
Now that's-that's not good. That's not good...
I don't like that..
*kid screaming*
AAAAAAAAA!
I can do that too.
ooOOHhh...!
What da hell?
What??
*Kid screaming*
Wha- wai- waaait a minute? Huh?
Aaah! I'm running! Oooh..hi. okay..
*kid screaming*
Ah! A reason! That sounds- o-kay?
Okay...
*Broken door creaks open*
*Weird noises*
What just happened?!
''Huh!? Someone's after my cookies.'' Oh...! Oh...
AH! Wh- Uh- Okay!
What the fuck?!
This doesn't- this is so broken!
How's this even-  This doesn't make any sense!
*broken door creaks open*
This is so broken. This game is broken. The game is like broken, broken.
I mean- Oh! Oka-
Would!-
Are you not supposed to go in? Is that what I'm supposed to get here. You're not supposed to go. You just-
You're not supposed to go in the amazing door that has nothing in it. Wow, that door is off its hinges *laughter*
That door didn't reset right. Oh, this- this don't even move right. Well hi, hello! Welcome to the neighborhood.
I'm just gonna leave, you know? I don't even understand anything that's happening here. This makes NO sense.
Yup. Can't do that. *jumps* I'M- I wanna leave! I just wanna leave!
What is happening!?
I don't understand you! I wanna go now!
I can't leave. Can't leave.
Can't leave!
Ya can't move, ya can't leave! So I won't leave, I won't move! Can't pick dat up!
If I move, I die!
If I move, I die! Welp! This is fun!
OH- okay. No, I can't go that way. Alright, let me try this again
So alright, I re-install the game, so I'm back here now. Okay. Let's try this again. Shall we?
throw
Nice. Open- oh. What?
Wait what? Oh.
*Broken door freaks out*
That door is NOT normal! What is happening!? I don't understand. I don't understand.
''Press E t-'' oooh!
*realization hits* Wow, wowie. Wow. Wow. Wooow! Oh wow!
Oh gee Scoo- Oh gee Scoob! Oh gee Scoob!
Ohh, gee Scoob
I'm trying to hide- ouh- that way, there we go. Okay. I hid!
Alrighty then! Hmm. Hi. Whu- whut!?
*Confused markimoo*
EUGHHH
Okay, everything's fine
It's a beta. Okay. All right now that we're out of that..
weeeird world, I don't know what the hell is happening there. I have no idea!
I haven't got the foggiest clue, and why is this exactly like my apartment in the city?! It's the exact same!
They just transplanted it here. What is this?!
What is this!? I'm so confuuUUsed!
It seems like the quality has degraded! I can't believe this. I want- you know, okay, alright
I'm goofing around a bit, but also
Why did this regress? Why did this game go backwards in terms of development? Why did this game
go backwards in terms of, like any sort of finesse to it. Ya know what I mean?
It just seems like it's a little lackluster here. Alright whatever Anyway,
I'm gonna try to explore and see whatever is new, but it looks like there's a lot of pieces that are still the same
As what they once were
Is this a pile-a-poo? Is this where all the dead bodies be? Where's that crow? Crow! *laughter* Crow!
CROW!
Crow?? (is it dead?)
Crow. Bird?
Raven! Sorry. Took me a while to get there, but Raven. How are you doing? You okay? You guarding this box?
It's a nice box. You mind me sitting in your box?
Mr.Crow?- Raven, sorry
Blackbird?
Hello? You there?
Bird! You want a red key?
You want- you want pizza bowx?
You want trashcan lihd?
Nope. Bird!
Hello?! Bird!
Birb? Come on Birb!
Apple core! *throw at* Birb. Boink!
Birb gotta eat. Birb gotta eat, baby. Birb gotta eat. aAH! About to throw my key in anger! Well key disappeared into the ground not- *sound of neighbor coming*
S'cuse you! Feedin' the birbs here!
You're nose shank over time buddy-boo. I don't know how that happened. Right anyway, just got deal with your bird
I don't know what this word means. Pat- paternble..webn. Is that your name? Mr. Webin, Mr. Paternable
You want Chinese food?
You want Chinese takeout? BIRB! It's free food right there you get your noodles! How about empty milk carton.
Calcium good for your booOnes
No? Maybe I gotta get in your box. Beh...
You doin' good bird. You get- you get box in box. All right, good day to you birb! Have a nice!
Take care! Much love.. love-love. Well anyway, let's see if I can do the ol' razzle-dazzle on 'em
HWAH *throws tire* oh, you will never see me. *sneaky*
You will never hear that ever-  uh...wat?
How did you see? How t-uh...? How can you slap? Well don't even t-...I'm going in your house.
Doodly-Doo! Gonna lock you out. Doodly-doo. You've been locked out mother humper
Eat a lotta dicks...eat a lot of dicks. It's so good for you full of pro-tin (protein). Ah! Ah! Nope! That was wrong
Uwahh...missing my Target
Hey up-ty!
HYUUP-TY. Okay good. I got into your glue collection. Well this all seems similar. Anything new here?
Nope
HU-BUSKEY
Good thing I don't have that red key anymore. I probably could have used it would have been too
unfair advantage for me. Ah!
An um- brlr. Maybe Birb'll like this
Welp, that went places. Just like I'm going
Huh, I wonder how this works again. WHOoah!
Well nah...not good enough apparently. HURR. I'm so grumpy!
God, my GRUMP levels are off the chart you getting umbrellrd. You get bur-
Oh sorry! I didn't mean to do that to your window
Hey, come here. Come here. Let me have a conversation with you man-to-man. Hey, buddy. Buddy-boo
Going in your house! Doodly-doo! Doodly-doo. Hahahahahahahah loser. Alright, goosh! Goosh!
Take trois! (Take 3 even though it's his second take)
Scoosh! De-douche. right, so there. We got this whole deal. Can't do much about it. *lunging picture frame* uh-HUH!
Nope. UH! Well, that didn't work. GUH!
HUBOINK'DEE. Oh well that's weird. HUBOOSHKE. Alright. That didn't work. BRESKY...Nope...HIBIKI.
Okay, well you keep an eye on that.
(haha! coz it's an eye! no?) I'm gonna go try do something else
I need something small enough to be able to throw through the little gap in the back to be able to get to
the lever. Alright Paternable, you ain't gonna mind if I take this, do ya Paternable?
Peculiar over there, huh, weird huh..
Scoosh! Alright I'll see if I can- *creepy music of neighbor coming* Why?!
Who and what and how?! And who did that- you son of a bitch. AH!
I just wanted your left over takeout! AAAH!
Help me, please!
Aeeyaeat...10,000 cocks!
Alright, watch dis. I'm gonna be stealthy. You ain't gonna see shit cuz I'm crouching all of a sudden.
Oh! Somehow you heard that. How did you-oh! You got close! Well you-you-you, that's not okay.
He's grumpy now! He's real grumpy. Well I hit that patch of glue
Alright. Chinese takeout! *throw* Oh! I think that did it! That did it though! I hit it. I heard a squeak!
Ah well good, It's night. Hopefully- *car zooms past* oOOHHOHOHOHOHohoh!
Why is he tangled up in the fence over there? That's so funny
*Gets caught in bear trap* Ow! Meant to- Meant to not do that, but did it anyway
Ooh! Hello Chinese takeou- WOOOAHH
Going up! I'm going up. I don't know where I'm going, but I'm going up
Nice!
Where am I now?
Ooh, where's this? Hello!
Nothing. I didn't bring a flshlight, not a flesh light. *laughs* I didn't bring a flashlight.*falls* *get's stuck in wall* IIII BROKE IT!
OOH FUUUUUUUU-
Well, shit. Lemme see if I can squiggle out of this one. I've got some pretty good squiggling skills
Nope. Ain't no sqwoogling is gonna get me out of this one. I'm gonna.. be right back. Oh good, I still have my apple core! Hey, buddy
Hey, buddy. D'ya mind if I go right in your front door? Oh yeah, sure you do. Oh, yeah here I go!
He didn't even notice. What do you do?? *pulls lever* oh!
AH! Why?! Why game? I- oooh! I'm in the wall AGAIN!
Really? Wow. Game?
Oh man, I wanna like ya! I wanna like ya game, but you god damn..! Okay. Alright.
There's the gap.
Don't wanna go shop at the gap.
TA-DA! Made it out of the gap! That was- that was a close call! What's this piece of wood?
Nothin'!
Alright. Why are we here? Huh! What did that do? I'm not 100% sure.
Ugh!
Okay, made it here. Why- eugh this did me no good did it?
Oh good, great. I wasn't supposed to come here...
Euuh! I'm gonna slide right off the roof if I try to go that way so,
I'm gonna go the only way that seems logical! Which is to go over there. Not logical, but ya know. Ooh! What about that?
I see you right there! Can I land on you?
Think I can! Whoop!
Doodly-doo! Scoosh! Hey, hey buddy. Hey, buddy. How you doin'? Keeping an eye watchful eye. It's good. That's good
Ooh! What's this? Is this a- ooh.
Whyyy is there a traain?
Excuse you!
Good to know this big red button did absolutely dick.
Oh! It did not do dick. It did more than dick. It did- woo. Ah.
Must sacrifice this apple core! HUH!
It's
Well, that's happening now..Not sure what to do about that. *falls* Ooh AH!
Ah. Made it safely here. *barriers fall* *confused markioo* Whuuuuuuut?
Oh! It smashed open the doobers! It smashed the doobers. Okay, so if it smashed the doobers, then I'm going to d- aahhh... *creepy noises*
I got a peel! I got an 'nana peel. Here's the hole. I wanna go in the hole.
Hole in! I should have turned it off, shouldn't I have. Should I have not have done that.
Well, testing fate with walking on this. Oh there it is! Good! That's far away from me. That's gonna be fine. Alright, cool.
Why does he have this?
Why does he have this at all? Why is this a thing that he has?
Where is it... Where is it? Oh there it is! Oh hi!
Oh yes, plea- okay fuck you then too! Great.
Let me try... where does this lead?
Ooohh! This leads this way! Where does this lead?
oOOHh! Here I is! Rock me- didn't want to go in here- Rock me like a hurricane!
Interesanté. Aaahhh!
I can control-oo it now.
Sorry
Still got my 'nana peel. Never gonna let go of my 'nana peel.
Nice drop into nothingness. I don't think I want to go there just yet
So this is the control room that I just was, were at.
Turn that son of a bitch off
Stop! Good. Okay, you stay there for a little bit. You rest your weary head.
Oh oh!
Well that did nothing. Okay great. Glad I did that okay, let me follow the tracks for a little bit longer
Chuggle-a-chuggle-a-chuggle-a. Look at me chuggle-a-go! Right, so this is just back to where I was
What is- what is- what is that?
S'cuse you, what- S'cuse you what? What is that?
*creepy music of neighbor coming* What? Oh. Why? He's never gonna be able to get me here. If he's able to get me here. I'm a monkey's... butt hole..
I know this is gonna work because I've definitely done this before and it's worked before, every time I wanted to do this.
Every time it's worked flawlessly.
Yep, that's part of the flawless plan. Alright, here we go.
Flawless! Flawless! FLawless! Ah
William Wallace Flawless. Huh! Okay, not quite.
Oh! I'm right there! Aww, I was right there! Get out of my face. Yeah.
Oh yeah! Made it. Made it. What did I win? Frying pan. That's what I won.
Why's frying pan on the wall? Don't ask too many que- okay that... also happened..
Oh, bye knocks. We're for frying pan.
Oh! That's weird!
Why are- oh green key!
You're up here for some reason. I can't even grab you. You're not- you don't exist. I forgot, this is ''beta''. Ah yes, ''beta''.
Aah, yes. ''Beta''.
Well that didn't work. I brought you all this way 'nana peel. It didn't work.
Don't know why I thought it would have worked, but it didn't work.
Ya know what I think that's enough Mayhem for one episode I'm gonna end this one here. I criticize it a lot just because like-
There's a lot more stuff, but I can't honestly say that the stuff is better.
And that's the one thing that I'll say about it, because I'm expecting as the game develops is going to get like more
logical and sensible and, you know, it just seems even more nonsensical than it was before. So there's a lot more, but its less refined.
You know what I mean. What is happening in there?
What the hell?
What is happening in there?
I don't know what's happening, but I'm gonna try to get in that window.
Nope. Wow! Okay! Well, this- I expected to slide off of this and I didn't!
Alrighty then!
How much farther can I go on the- I'M NOT FARTHER! EUGH!
I'm dead now apparently. Okay. But either way, that is all the time I've got for Hello Neighbor.
Thank you everybody so much for watching this. Probably new secrets in this version of Hello Neighbor
but,
my God is it uglier! So thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you thought down in the comments below.
Is it better? Is it worse? I dunno! And thanks again for watching and as always I will see you in the next video!
Buh- Bye!